so what was carl jung's opinions on ufos
i know he had a whole book on ufos
he did yeah
um
i forgot the name of it but it has
flying saucers in the oh it's called the
modern flying saucers the modern myth in
the sky
okay
and um his views changed so at first he
viewed this as
uh he viewed ufos as an archetype like
this new archetype that he was figuring
out
but then he met a lot of people in the
government who actually had physical
they showed him radar reports and things
like that and so then he was like wow
and then he had friends who he found to
be credible tell him about their own
experiences of seeing ufos so then he
started to realize that this
idea of an archetype actually had a
physical component to it
and then the last thing he wrote about
it was a letter where he basically said
i think he honestly didn't know kurt
because i i mean if you read it because
i tried to read everything that i could
possibly get when i was writing american
cosmic that carl jung said about ufos
and what i came up with was that he
changed his mind a couple of different
times but the last thing he thought was
that
and i think you could see it in this
letter and i think i cite it somewhere
in my book is basically
yeah he says it's an archetype but it's
an archetype that has physical qualities
to it which i thought was really weird
yeah
that makes it unexampled in the
pantheon of archetypes
yeah so they have physical components so
much as well they are physical and so
much as they interact with ourselves and
we interact with the physical world but
not themselves
yes so this is interesting so let's talk
about this for a second okay so right
right now i'm looking at um there's a
person and again i will have to send you
because i like to give credit where
credit's due but unfortunately i read so
much stuff i forget the names of people
but this is a person who calls himself
uh
a story technologist so he does like
he's a tech he says that um he does the
history of stories and he looks he uses
basically tons and tons of data just to
break down different stories and to show
how they actually
like what they do to our brains okay
and um i'll send you a link to his work
but what i think is really interesting
is i agree with him that there was a
point in time when writing became a
technology right and so with writing
stories were able to be written down and
so people like plato and socrates said
well there's a new technology and like
aristotle did an analysis of the
technology of stories and he said these
are you know in a sense that's what carl
jung was doing when he was talking about
archetypes so he's talking about kind of
the elements that create these stories
that get told from culture and culture
again and again and again like the
hero's journey okay so this kind of this
mythine you know
um
would you call it a theme yeah that's
levi strauss called it
it wasn't a myth because it was more
than a myth it was actually the the very
unit that created the different myths
right
okay so all right so if i'm looking at
stories as technology when i went back
to american cosmic and in order to to
try to push the method in my field i had
to embody and inhabit what i called a
myth which was the myth of prometheus i
had to actually live it and i was super
uncomfortable doing that
and then after that what happened was
in my next book i've morphed into a new
myth
embodying inhabiting a new myth and that
myth is basically the allegory of the
cave which is by the way not called an
allegory that was a later imputation so
this idea of the cave which by the way
we see it again and again and again with
like the truman show or the matrix you
know it gets played out in so many
different ways in our culture right now
um that we live in a simulation the
simulation hypothesis is basically
another iteration of this missing okay
new when referring to jung and the
archetype that you considered ufos to be
a new archetype but my understanding of
archetypes is that there's a timeless
nature to them and that the
representations can be new
like we could all be orbiting the same
object and representing it differently
but the object itself that is trying to
be represented isn't new so did you
actually say that there was a new object
somehow
no he didn't necessarily what he said
was that this was a new um he didn't
even call it a religion he called it a
new myth
but not the myth you know not
the type of myth that we see when we say
oh greek myth or something like that
which basically are religions you know
if you look at greek myth
this was religion for weeks back in that
time period so um
yeah so i think that is it new um it
doesn't look to be new um but the ways
in which humans engage with it i think
are new absolutely